au milieu de la nuit une vitrine colorée
illumine la rue de la boétie
c'est ici que l'île de la réunion
tourisme a rénové son antenne au centre
de paris
pour l'occasion la diaspora parisienne
des vedettes réunionnaise a fait le
déplacement
les réunionnais sont tous des
ambassadeurs de leur île c'est important
de mettre le réunionnais au coeur du
tourisme à la réunion
donc les réunionnais qu'ils soient
professionnels qu'ils soient
ambassadeur qu'on a nommé il ya quelques
temps et puis les professionnels de
façon générale les tour-opérateurs et
l'ensemble des partenaires avec qui on
travaille
d'importants qu'ils vivent le lieu qu'on
se rend compte dans des espaces parfois
un peu détendus et à l'occasion de cette
inauguration des bureaux de bière
préparée pour exemple le potentiel
touristique des pitons cirques et
remparts de la forêt départementaux de
manial illustre que le tourisme est une
affaire collective
raison pour laquelle la présidente du
conseil départemental a souhaité montrer
son engagement dans cette dynamique
collective
la réunion ii peut vendre que c'est
l'image et donc joué collectif c'est une
nécessité au moment où effectivement les
territoires ont de moins en moins de
moyens financiers
lyon pour faire exister nos territoires
et donc aujourd'hui avec lire le
président de yaté mais il est maire
d'une commune rurale à fort potentiel
était tous ici salazie fait partie du
peur du par pour une partie de son
territoire des communes qui attire
effectivement le touriste européen voire
au delà de l'europe ceux des pays de la
deuxième zone
ceux de l'inde de la chine et je sais
que le président biya tu es bien de
faire un voyage en chine pour
effectivement aller toucher le coeur des
touristes chinois
oui même ambition portée par l'ensemble
des partenaires nous sommes la région
réunion
dis à tes les tablettes évidemment mon
conseil départemental les
intercommunalités et surtout les
professionnels du tourisme
je veux ajouter peut-être un clin d'oeil
aux chefs d'entreprise
parce qu'en créant de l'activité ils
peuvent aussi faire en sorte que le
département de la réunion l'île de la
réunion puisse garder son savoir faire
le savoir est tous créoles et les nappes
un lieu de rencontre et d'échangé mais
surtout le promotion de l'île de la
réunion
c'est ce qui est important c'est que les
touristes viennent nombreux jeunes au
territoire des nombreux à la réunion
et c'est cet espace de des changes et
surtout d'information est important pour
le monde du tourisme et pour notre
oksibil cette île aux mille visages aux
mille paysages cette plateforme
permettra notamment une interaction avec
les professionnels du tourisme
de quoi faire du bien à tout le
département